two good Samaritans are being praised
for helping a little girl to safety
after her apparently suicidal father
jumped in front of a moving New York
City subway train while holding the
little girl dramatic cell phone video
captured the rescue after the youngster
survived and crawled to safety from
underneath the Train Meg Oliver shows us
what happened
a miraculous sight in the tracks of a
New York subway station early Monday
morning
this five year-old girl with only minor
injuries crawling on the tracks from
underneath the southbound train highroad
Torrez Dean in the white t-shirt jumped
down to pull the girl to safety she told
me like I what happened to my daddy and
then I said don't look at your daddy
come to me come like a puppy according
to police sources the 45 year old father
was holding his daughter's wrist when he
intentionally jumped from the platform
just after 8:00 a.m. the train was not
able to stop in time and the father was
killed the man that I saw jump in had a
little girl in his wrist and in his arms
next thing I know he and her jumped they
believed the girl survived by lying flat
between the tracks after being treated
for minor scrapes and bruises she was
carried home by her Godfather the girl's
mother says my little girl is in perfect
condition thanks to God and the angels
that protected her for CBS this morning
Meg Oliver New York you can tell the
people that watched it are traumatized
but I love that the Samaritan said to
her crawl like a puppy yeah as you talk
to a little child in there words that
they understand yes good people they're
on the platform